[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
Wanda welcome home vision residence
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my breakdown of the Loki
trailer footage is gonna be premiering
next year in 2021 before Doctor Strange
2 comes out so I'll explain all the
easter eggs they're sitting up a really
big multiverse story that's gonna spill
into a lot of the other series as well
as the future movies to it introduced a
couple really big multiverse level
villains like King the Conqueror we've
been doing that infinity saga box set
giveaway for all the movies all you have
to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave all your theories
about what they're gonna do on the Loki
series so just starting with the footage
it picks up with him being held by the
Marvel Time variants Authority in one of
their prison cells as denoted by the
jumpsuit that he's wearing with the
initials TVA as Loki tends to do in
situations like this where his backs
against the wall he spits of them saying
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
is great it's a complete and utter
low-key thing of him to do how did he
get there who would the time variance
Authority and because this is a Loki
from an alternate reality after avengers
endgame in the Loki series is premiering
after one division but before Doctor
Strange two multiverse of madness and
Thor for love and thunder in a lot of
those things are trading heavy on the
concept of the multiverse maybe not
necessarily Thor for what does the Loki
series and episodes have to do with all
that stuff how are they going to
crossover because the plot of all the
Disney Plus series are supposed to
affect what happens in the future movies
so whatever they're doing during Loki is
going to have a big ripple effect on
what goes forward so we'll just break
this down top five style if there's a
couple really cool Easter eggs in this -
especially some Fantastic Four stuff I
know you're all waiting for more news
about Marvel's new Fantastic Four movie
reboot don't worry I'll talk about that
during the video but starting with
number five this is the Loki from
Avengers endgame who stole the tesseract
during 2012 in the events of the first
Avengers movie Tom Hiddleston recently
revealed that not a lot of time will
have passed for him when the series
picks up in Loki episode 1 but based on
the plot synopsis of the series he'll be
jumping around in time the multiverse
really comes into play because 2012
Avengers Loki created an alternate
timeline branching out from 2012 when he
took the tesseract even if you weren't
happy with the way they explained all
the mechanics of time-travel and
alternate realities you have to go based
on the logic that they set up so the
ancient one has that
PowerPoint tutorial that she gives the
Hulk is the whole reason why Captain
America had to take the Infinity stones
back to where they stole them from at
the end of the movie and he says to
Bruce don't worry I'll clip all the
branches as in branching timelines so
number four if Loki had the tesseract
and an infinite ability to travel
anywhere he wanted how did he wind up in
this prison cell and who are the
time-variant authority who will
presumably be the antagonist of the
series since Breaking Bad style the
protagonist of the series is Loki it's
something of an antihero it's much
easier to understand how he got captured
once you understand who the time parents
Authority is and they appeared in the
Marvel Comics for the first time in Thor
number 372 in 1986 during a Thor time
travel story so no surprise that they're
debuting in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for the first time in a Thor
related story via Loki but they also
interacted a lot and crossed over with
the Fantastic Four in the comics I'll
get to that in a second - real quick
explainer for them though the time
variance Authority claims responsibility
for monitoring the multiverse and can
prune timelines quote unquote if they're
deemed too dangerous to exist they also
take action to prevent other beings from
altering the past or future and despite
their claims the time periods
authorities influence over time is not
absolute there are a couple really big
Marvel time-travel villains that they've
never been able to stop including King
the conquer in a couple others from the
past the official plot synopsis of the
Loki series has him traveling through
time messing with major events in
Earth's history causing all kinds of
mischief the time variant Authority
probably detects this and moves to
capture him and that's probably how he
winds up in this cell number three what
does this have to do with Thor for love
and thunder Wanda vision in Doctor
Strange 2 multiverse of madness so let's
start with Thor 4 because it would be
weird to have a big Thor movie and not
have Loki cameo in some way but the main
version of Loki from Thor's timeline
died during Avengers infinity war and
this Loki is alternate reality Loki who
never got any of the redemption our core
character development through Marvel
phase 2 phase 3 and because not a lot of
time will have gone by from the end of
Avengers endgame when he escaped with
the tesseract in the beginning of Loki
episode 1 Tom Hiddleston says that the
last thing he remembers is getting
thrashed
by the Hulk so he is really pissed off
and he's escaped Odin's justice and just
as wild as ever so early speculation
they will find a way for this version of
Loki to be involved in Thor for a little
bit and it'll have something to do with
the version of Mjolnir that Jane Foster
Thor winds up wielding but nothing that
they've said about Thor force so far
even the Christian Bale stuff
screams multiverse so that's why I'm
thinking that Loki if he does appear
during Thor 4 it'll be a relatively
minor role there's a bit of a Rick and
Morty connection to this - the time
variant authority is kind of like the
Citadel of Rick's and the showrunner on
the low key series came from Rick and
Morty so it sounds like Marvel is
looking for that kind of energy with the
time variant authority we just keep him
here because he's fun think of tesseract
low-key as c-137 Rick trying to jump
around and do whatever he wants to do
escaping the authority of the Citadel
who's trying to chase him down and stop
him they are already talking about doing
a low-key season - I don't know
with the Plata that would be because we
haven't seen loki season 1 yet so it's
still wide open to speculation because
some of these Marvel series we didn't
know if they were gonna do season 2 but
it sounds like some of them might get
multiple seasons so number two the
Doctor Strange - multiverse of madness
in one division connection I think is
purely just because time-traveling Loki
will lead to the creation of more
multiple realities causing chaos for the
multiverse and for the most part Doctor
Strange - is gonna be them battling
nightmare or Mephisto or another major
villain from the multiverse with the
help of Scarlet Witch and thus they'll
also be traveling around the multiverse
just like Loki but I don't expect Loki
to have a really major role in Doctor
Strange - maybe a small cameo or a
mention because he and Doctor Strange
have history it even though the Loki he
had history with wound up dying during
infinity war Loki was on dr. strange
[ __ ] list since the minute he became
sorcerer supreme so wouldn't matter
which version of Loki was traveling
around the multiverse trying to change
the timeline Doctor Strange would still
try to keep an eye on his whereabouts
but number one WTF obviously what about
Fantastic Four in King the conquer I
think everybody's just wondering because
the time variant Authority multiverse
villains just screams Kang the Conqueror
especially when you get into
time-traveling like I said the time
variant authority shows up a bunch
during Fantastic Four
stories attempting to discipline them
for damage they believe the team has
done to the multiverse through their
time travel and jumping between
realities but unsuccessful I might add
the Fantastic Four are much smarter than
the time parent's authority we all know
that Marvel is working on a new
Fantastic Four movie reboot Kevin Feige
set it back at comic-con uh all of that
is spoilers but I'm extremely excited
about those characters and about and
about bringing Marvel's first family up
sort of to the platform and the level
that they deserve see all the stuff we
did today teases I just didn't have time
to talk about it
based on all the information we have so
far I don't think that they're gonna
release that till 2022 or 2023 but
because one division is going to confirm
the space station Nick Fury was on in
the spider-man far from home post-credit
scene is actually the sword space
station from the comics in the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the big
Avengers level stuff the big team based
stuff is going more cosmic and more
multiverse with the villains and the
stories it makes sense that they'll use
the Loki episodes to world build a lot
more like the way you see Rick and Morty
go to alternate realities just world
building constantly making things seem
bigger and bigger and bigger this where
you encounter characters like Kang the
Conqueror
he doesn't have to show up on the Loki
episodes but you can name-drop him so
that in the future when he shows up in a
movie he's a much bigger threat because
you've already laid that track work
there's still theories about how they're
gonna handle the Marvel Fantastic Four
reboot how they'll handle the origin
story are they gonna already have their
powers at the beginning of the movie
will it be like the Doctor Strange movie
well they'll tell it in a slightly
nonlinear way or even make them
scientists working on the sword Space
Station and then it just gets hit by
cosmic energy waves and that's how they
get their powers it's still wide open to
theory crafting so post all your
Fantastic Four theories in the comments
king is also a really big Avengers level
villain so if they don't use them in a
movie first he'd be great as a young
avengers Disney Plus Series villain in a
couple years once they introduce all
those team members if you include all
the characters they already have in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and then the
ones that they just announced recently
that they almost have the full original
comic book Young Avengers roster
including Wiccan and speed which they
just introduced in The Scarlet Witch
Wanda vision trailer but everyone post
all your theory
in the comments how do you think the
Loki series will crossover with Thor for
Doctor Strange - and do you think
they'll introduce Kang the Conqueror as
a sort of fan oast level figure on the
Loki series I've got a bunch more Marvel
and Mandalorian Season 2 videos coming
up if there's any special videos you
want me to do just let me know in the
comments but everyone click here for my
new Doctor Strange - special
announcement breakdown it's Pizza time
and click here for my Wanda vision
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you